so what's happening in Massachusetts is
happening in other democrat-led
Sanctuary cities and states and now one
headline warns the blue State migrant
crisis Sparks political disaster for
Biden Molly Hemingway Fox News
contributor and editor-in-chief of the
Federalist joins me now Molly this is a
disaster I mean there's just no question
about it and really there is no sense of
urgency it seems coming from the White
House well it is interesting though
President Biden was very clear when he
ran for office in 2020 he opened his
campaign with a pledge to essentially
open the border and reverse the policies
the immigration policies of his
predecessor and on day one when he took
office he did
issue where he repealed or turned away
the executive orders that President
Trump had put in place and really worked
to have the poorest border that we have
now which enables not just human
trafficking but also drug trafficking
and other issues but he was very clear
about it and so you see all these
Democrat run States and and
municipalities now being very upset
about it but this was not an issue of
where they should necessarily be
surprised the only surprising thing is
that blue states are dealing with what a
lot of these red border states have been
dealing with for for many years now
axios has an interesting article and I
just want to quote something from it
because they explain why it matters for
those of you at home that may wonder why
we keep talking about this President
Biden is stuck between growing calls to
help the democratic-controlled cities
the politics of the vulnerable issue and
what the administration views as legal
handcuffs prohibiting much action that
is sort of a trifecta of where the
president finds himself this shouldn't
be about politics this shouldn't be
about about placating and and and and
trying to make the left happy you've got
left leaning Democratic cities who are
absolutely frustrated New York City for
for example are full of Democrats they
hate the fact that these illegal
immigrants are taking over shelters and
areas where our children should be
playing in Parks it has nothing to do
with being against immigrants it has to
do with Democratic Leadership making
mistakes and not listening to the voters
well you just Molly line just reported
that Massachusetts had declared a state
of emergency for handling their migrant
crisis that they're that they have there
the New York State Governor Kathy hokel
has asked the federal government to
declare a state of emergency you have
Eric Adams asking for federal help but
they're not really getting it and you're
starting to hear you know reliable
allies of President Biden like Senator
Dick Durbin of Illinois saying he
doesn't understand why it's taking so
long he's been notifying President Biden
for some time it does not seem I don't
know if it's a our issue where the
Democrats do not want the the Biden
Administration doesn't want to admit how
much their border policies have failed
they really did put a lot of effort and
work it was intentional to do what they
did with the Border it wasn't an issue
where neglect where they weren't just
paying attention and all of a sudden we
have a we have a migrant crisis no this
was intentional so it might be hard for
them to admit how much they have failed
or how much how much harm they're
causing key Democrat allies allies but
does not seem they're moving on it yeah
and you know the president hasn't even
bothered to meet with some of these
Democratic leaders for example the
governor here Kathy hokel she I'm sure
would love to have Biden's ear if he
actually came here and saw it or heard
from the Democratic lawmakers themselves
about what a mistake this is maybe he
would do something about it but rather
than worry about votes we've got a
humanitarian crisis in our own American
cities
well it's uh it's been bad for years now
and it it the the tempo or the the
people are getting much more upset about
it so it will be hard to avoid it
particularly because President Biden is
heading into a campaign when he ran in
2020 he had very friendly media coverage
he had a lot of support now you've got a
lot of these issues it's not just the
Border but a lot of other issues where
he's not going to be able to hide from
dealing with with them as he's trying to
win votes uh headed into the next year
yeah no certainly and this could hurt
him badly and that's unfortunate it is a
politic you know it's purely politics
that's what this is uh mauling Hemingway
thank you great to see you always uh
thank you have a good one thank you you
too thanks hey everyone I'm Emily
compagno catch me and my co-host Harris
Faulkner and Kaylee mcineny on
outnumbered every weekday at 12 pm
Eastern or sets your DVR also don't
forget to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page for daily highlights